and in the nfl we saw several teams
cancel practice on thursday we knew
yesterday that a couple of teams were
going to specifically washington which
had a scrimmage set
at fedex field the cardinals bears
broncos packers
colts chargers jets and titans
joined the washington football team
in not practicing on thursday
other teams considered it talked about
it decided the right thing for them to
do was to go
forward it was a team by team case by
case city by city type of a
determination
at the end of the day the nfl and the
nfl players association issued a joint
statement
showing that there is unity between
labor and management now how far that
goes to each and every team and
management of each and every team
remains to be seen
but they made it clear via the joint
statement that there
is a united movement more than ever to
support one another in these challenging
times and
shared anger and frustration most
recently as a result of the shooting of
jacob blake
so that that that was a positive
development shireen
and the lions were at the forefront on
tuesday and two days later nine more
teams choose not to practice
and that's a lot to give up a day of
practice when
we're in a compressed pre-season
environment
with no joint practices no preseason
games
limited opportunities to get ready it
shows you how important this issue
is to a lot of the nfl's players and
coaches
that there was a willingness to shut it
down for a day and focus on these issues
instead
yeah no question and you can't criticize
either side mike
for those teams that that chose to sit
out
practice and a lot of those coaches made
those decisions before they ever talk to
their teams
you know cliff kingsbury had some great
comments and
and uh a bunch of them did and and it
was fantastic
but those teams that choose to practice
chose to practice yesterday and will
choose to practice today i don't think
you can criticize them either
you know as the giants pointed out i
think it was leonard williams who said
it you know i
these young guys need a chance to make
the roster and they need every
day to prove to the team that they they
should be on
on the roster and losing a day of
practice is huge for them and you get
that
so you can't criticize the teams that
chose to practice and you can't
criticize those that didn't because it
was important to them it was bigger than
football that day
so you know teams made a team by team
decision on what their leadership
what it meant to them and and how they
wanted to proceed and go forward and
and even those teams that practiced i
think this was big for them they at
least talked about it in their meetings
yesterday and i'm sure they'll continue
to talk about it it's a big deal
well and i will say this though for the
teams that did practice
there is a chance there is a chance that
the head coach did not properly read the
room
there's a chance and there may be an
aftermath there may be a blowback there
may be a reaction haven't seen any of
that yet which i think is encouraging
but i think that's the challenge for
every coach in a situation like this
taking the temperature of the locker
room
and deciding what the players
collectively want
do they want to practice are they able
to to focus
on practicing football could it become a
potential risk to them
if they go out and try to practice on a
day when they're distracted
by events going on elsewhere and
distracted by
a desire to talk about social justice
issues and not focus on football for the
day so it was a team by team type of a
thing
and and we'll see maybe maybe for some
teams they practiced yesterday
they don't practice today some teams had
yesterday off what are they going to do
today so this is going to continue to
linger
through the weekend but i think the fact
that the nba is going forward
makes it easier to come to the
conclusion that the nfl will go
forward but you know there's still that
that nagging possibility that in any
given moment
another video is going to emerge of
another incident that is going to be
troubling to the fair-minded
and human-hearted objective person who
sees it and says
what in the hell is going on there
that could operate as jet fuel on these
embers because that's the thing
this is going to be embers this fire is
not going to go out completely
and that fire can flare up at any time
if and when there's another one of these
incidents
and every time we think okay maybe we're
not going to see one of these for a
while
one of these happens and and that
shireen at any point between labor day
and super bowl sunday that's going to be
a factor if it happens in the nfl what
will occur if there's another incident
like this you know we're worried about
covet 19 outbreaks and false positives
another thing to factor into what the
nfl needs to be worrying about
if there's another incident like this
what is it going to do is it going to
shut down practice is it going to shut
down games
the league has been fortunate so far
because covet happened during their off
season so they had months to prepare and
get ready and do all the things they
needed to do they didn't lose any games
to it like the other sports
and now the videos that have come out
with george
floyd and jacob blake have happened
either during their off season program
or during training camp so again
they haven't had to make those decisions
but if these things like you said
keep happening and one comes out i think
we've had the precedent
set i am not going to be at all
surprised if we lose
some or all of an nfl sunday if
something like this happens
uh during a week and we see another
video and it comes out
these players again have realized that
they have this platform
and they're a little more powerful maybe
than they thought they were and so
uh yeah if this comes out again not
going to surprise me precedent has been
said i i think now that they
they i don't want to say have to do it
but they would
definitely lean toward not playing if
something happens like this again
and let's pray to god that it doesn't
well yeah
absolutely and you know we talked
yesterday about where is the finish line
in this effort for social justice
and you never quite know that you're
there if you get to a point where these
incidents stop
because we're always a news cycle away
from another one
and i i i just i hope that we get to a
point where
we can feel tangible progress other than
noticing boy it's been a year since the
last time we saw one of these horrifying
videos let's hear from some of the
voices in the national football league
shireen mentioned cliff kingsbury now
the second year coach of the arizona
cardinals
here's kingsbury who canceled practice
before even talking to the team
yesterday
explaining his decision to not have
practice on thursday
i think his players and coaches you know
we have a tremendous platform
and that can help keep the spotlight you
know on the fact that as a country
um we have issues uh when it comes to
social injustice and racism and
that we have a uh a problem here and
people pay attention when doc river
speaks
he's a guy that i know i um admire and
look up to in this profession and the
other
night when he put it it was so powerful
and so eloquent
um you know we talked about it as a team
the
people are talking about that and we
have that ability to to touch lives and
lead by example and i think that's what
we're all
all trying to do we all um need to push
together in the same direction
and you know try and and help the change
that we want to see
yeah and that's exactly the message it
needs to be sent and that's the platform
that needs to be used in that way
because it can
make a difference if enough voices are
heard if enough
pressure is applied it can make a
significant difference shireen
yeah and i think cliff kingsbury showed
his leadership you know
he's young he's barely older than these
players
and he really stood up and he made the
decision but one thing that really stood
out to me
is he said he talked to his father tim
his father tim is a long time football
coach
who served in the marines served in
vietnam and won a purple heart
and he asked him about players kneeling
for the national anthem and
cliff kingsbury's dad told him i don't
see it as a sign of disrespect
i don't see it as a lack of patriotism
he said in this situation i think you
have to respect everybody's opinion
and he said it's just like when you when
you stand up for the anthem it doesn't
mean that that you're for racism
and when you kneel it doesn't mean that
you're against the flag
and you're against patriotism and that
really stood out to me and i think uh it
convinced cliff too of some things and
he was great he was absolutely great
yesterday if you get a chance go read
all of his quotes
yeah and uh a a team that was great
yesterday at a time where some of the
teams were issuing statements some were
very short the jets statement was three
words enough is enough
you know we talk about how we turn this
moment into tangible action
and the baltimore ravens my goodness
they wrapped a whole statement around
the concept of enough is enough with
clear action items that they want to see
happen starting with
arresting and charging the police
officers responsible for killing brianna
taylor
and for the shooting of jacob blake an
amazing moment
for a sports team to come out and say
what so many individuals are saying and
then
calling out the senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell to bring the george
floyd
justice and policing act of 2020 to the
senate floor
for a vote and you know if you take away
qualified
immunity for police officers that forces
them to
think twice before they use
lethal force in situations where lethal
force may not be justified because they
no longer have that
shield from the legal system shireen
that allows them
to i hate to say it but
the old cliche shoot first and ask
questions later
because that's what they do right i mean
we've heard that term all our lives is
kind of an over the top hyperbole
but with qualified immunity that's what
they're allowed to do
because they don't get called out they
don't get questioned they don't get
placed in civil or criminal jeopardy
because the law is slanted in a way that
allows them
to use lethal force in situations where
you know a calm rational consideration
the facts
may make lethal force not justified and
for the ravens
to pivot from words to action with
specific
things that need to be done that's where
this movement needs to go it can't just
be
we're upset it has to be we're upset and
here's what needs to happen absolutely
this is bigger than a hashtag
and and that's kind of what everyone has
said it's got to be more than words it's
got to be more than statements and
the ravens hey if you want to know uh
what they want done here it is they
absolutely laid it out and if you saw on
on
twitter last night after they put that
out i mean it was one praise after
another praise and i'm sure there was
some in there that
had people upset but everything i saw
was oh my goodness if you want to see
action here's the action and and they
called for and they laid it out and they
said here it is this is what we need to
do to make this better
to move on to to find to end racism and
find some
social justice and they just laid it out
there and it was fantastic and and
hopefully it leads
to something but it's not just words
it's not just words on a paper they
offered something and i i i just thought
it was great
and you know they say the nfl is a
copycat league right
hey every other team every other team
take that statement and as as
sims would say to me copy paste copy
paste
just take that statement and put your
name on top of it the ravens are not
going to be upset
right if every team and wouldn't that be
great
if today every other team
just took that statement and issued that
same statement that would be powerful so
to the extent any of the other teams are
out there listening today
uh go ahead and do it and what are the
ravens going to complain
no they want these actions to happen and
the more people who stand up and call
for those actions
the actions become more likely to happen
one of the actions
that happened in pittsburgh was practice
went forward
and mike tomlin who's been the coach of
that team since 2007 he can read the
room like no other coach can read the
room
he decided to go forward he said they
didn't even consider not practicing
here's some of what tomlin had to say
uh we desire to have an impact and and
more so than statements and we want to
be proactive
in our behavior and our thoughts and so
we had continued conversations not
necessarily in reaction to
to the most recent events that have
transpired
um i i continue to appreciate the hearts
and spirits
of our players in terms of wanting to
participate and get
engaged in a positive way and express
themselves uh that
is their right um like i've said many
times they'll continue to be supported
by us
as long as their efforts are done so
thoughtfully and with class
and and so um i'm excited about
continuing to grow in that area as
is our football team and have an
understanding of our platform
and um and utilize it in a very positive
and constructive way but also understand
um that we're targets and our
perspectives and our opinions can be
weaponized for
agendas or against us and so we we
we want to move forward thoughtfully
with everything that we do
like we've mentioned uh we're excited
about being part of solutions if we can
be
it really is a sad commentary that
anyone who
believes that change needs to come in
this area
needs to be fearful that anything they
say
will somehow be used against them right
so it if you if you and look we we dealt
with this yesterday we're dealing with
it today my
email box was flooded with equal parts
praise and equal parts condemnation
for using this platform to bring light
to these issues and to
and to try to affect change but you know
that's something that
everyone in this arena is going to deal
with shireen any action you take
anything that you say
is potentially going to boomerang back
on you thrown at you by
by those who who just don't believe
don't agree
and don't see the need for change
yeah i found it interesting you know
there's four minority coaches in the nfl
and two did not practice yesterday
chose not to anthony lynn and ron rivera
the dolphins were off who have brian
flores as their head coach and
mike tomlin chose to to hold practice
and he does read the room as well as any
head coach in the nfl which is why he's
held his job as long as he has
and so this is an example of one size
doesn't fit all
every team is different ben
roethlisberger said this team didn't
take a vote but they did talk about it
and they talked about a lot and i know
every team in the nfl i guarantee you
i don't know it for a fact but i
guarantee you all 30 teams yesterday had
some sort of conversation
about these issues whether they
practiced or didn't practice
uh and and the steelers were one of
those teams that chose to practice and
are going to try to take it out
into the streets and do it in their
communities and find solutions and
and uh yeah you know mike tomlin he's
been great he's done a good job at it
and he'll continue to but he read his
room and he read his room as that team
needed to practice yesterday
there's one specific voice in the nfl
who is quickly building up the kind of
equity that insulates him from criticism
and he has a way of using the platform
that is not in any way threatening or
hostile it's very matter of fact and
it's patrick mahomes and he's made it
clear
that he's going to continue to use the
platform
for good here's some of what mahomes had
to say yesterday
they've done a good job of kind of
bringing in different people to talk to
us about social injustices and
then i think uh we've done a good job
amongst each other
of just getting each other's perspective
uh talking if
that's at lunch or if that's just in any
free time that we have because it is
it is something that's that's critical
in our in our country is how to find a
way to be better
and uh with the jacob blake shooting i
mean it's it's just
being transferred talking about it's
just crazy man that this is still going
on in the world that we live in today
and we're going to try to set the
example in whatever way possible
uh to show that we can get along and we
can really respect one another for who
they are
and not the color of their skin and
we're hoping that just that we can get
over this i mean
it's too long too long it's been too
long and we're going to try to get over
this and and get to where we all treat
each other
equally patrick toward that end you
became a voice in the social justice
movement
this off season what inspired you to do
so
like i said it's just been too long i
mean it's it's too much suffering it's
too much
uh people being treated differently and
i think i was just tired of it
i think everybody's been is tired of it
and it continues to happen and we have
to find a way to change
and i'm gonna be a voice i'm gonna do
whatever active whatever i can to
to make sure that we change and we can
make the world a better place and
whatever that takes uh travis is right
along with me we're gonna make sure that
we do
whatever it takes to put the world in a
better place yeah i think coach said it
best man everybody just got to love each
other and appreciate
uh one another for who they are their
differences
knowing that we all do have differences
we all have crazy
different upbringings um the people
around us uh
thought of mind things like that like
it's just everyone has to come together
and appreciate
uh everyone for who they are man and uh
until we have
that peace of mind
that was travis kelsey with patrick
mahomes being questioned by our friend
alex marvez's siriusxm nfl radio
refreshing to see a couple of guys in a
setting like that
wearing their masks not a lot of wearing
masks
on tv this week so it was good to see
that uh and
and look patrick mahomes shereen i
firmly believe
has the power
to make things happen because of how
good of a player he is
because of his personality and because
of his clear
unwavering commitment to it he doesn't
care about the blowback
and i don't know how much blowback he's
going to get and as he continues to
develop and mature as a player and a man
i think that as far as the nfl goes and
possibly as far as all american sports
go he could emerge
as the voice to lead us through this
boy hasn't he ascended quickly because
in two years he has become the face of
the nfl
that's what happens when you win a super
bowl mvp
and a league mvp which he's done over
the course of the last two years and
being the best player in the league
gives him a platform gives him a voice
and he's using that and
um you know he he's just come into this
to the league really and taking it by
storm and i think he's a perfect voice
for the nfl i think he's going to lead
this league
he's going to be the lebron james league
and i know that's big
saying that because there are so few
guys especially in the nfl that ascend
to that level
that really transcend the sport but i
think he's one of those generational
guys that's going to make a huge
difference
in so many ways in so many areas in the
nfl and in life and i think he's going
to make things better and
a great guy and he's done all the right
things so far and he's using that voice
now
and here's hoping that other young
quarterbacks in the nfl
don't just sit back and say patrick
you've got this
because i think just like with the
ravens as more teams say
hey yeah we agree with the ravens and
here's
our statement and it's the same as what
the ravens are saying
hopefully mahomes inspires other young
players especially quarterbacks because
they're the leaders on the field
to follow him and not just say go ahead
patrick
but to say we're right with you shoulder
to shoulder
yeah and i think it needs to be a lot of
the white quarterbacks and we saw it
with ryan tannehill
uh yesterday and a handful of others who
stood up there and
and stood with them and said the right
things and so yeah
it's got to be the quarterbacks because
they're the guys they're the faces
there's who they are who we
talk about so they need to be the ones
leading this charge and mahomes is the
leader of the leaders
but those other quarterbacks need to
step up to and and and come to the
forefront and be
big in this and look it's not just the
teams it's not
just the players the league office needs
to be part of this as well
and troy vincent the executive vp of
football operations was on espn radio
yesterday and
he was emotional his comments were
powerful and it
brings back a point that we made just
about at this same moment yesterday
that it's not necessarily concern about
what happens
to you it's concerned about what happens
to your children
because your children are
eventually turned loose into the world
and if you are a parent
of black children and you have to have
that
fear every time they leave your sight
every time they pull away in a car
and you don't know what's going to
happen to them if there's an interaction
with police
that is terrifying it's horrifying and i
think that
is for many of the adult males in the
sports world
who have children who are black that is
the concern
and it's it is if there is no greater
concern
than that if you haven't heard what troy
vincent had to say yesterday the emotion
in his voice the passion in his voice
i i recommend you tracking it down and
listening to that audio
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports